hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren wir schauen uns heute gemeinsam
die Doppelmoral von Katja krasavice an
[Musik]
die Passagen wo sie singt überspringen
wir Katja kommt aus sozial schwachen
Verhältnissen und musste mehrere
tragische Schicksalsschläge verkraften
jetzt wo sie selbst so erfolgreich und
reich ist möchte sie andere unterstützen
ich habe meinen Bestimmungen
da habe ich einen kleinen Skandal auf
tiktok zu mitbekommen
dass Sie in diesem Video so sagt hey ich
möchte Menschen helfen blablabla aber
ihr müsst mir dafür folgen und meinem
Eistee Account folgen und keine Ahnung
was also ich weiß nicht worum es hier
geht um welche Doppelmoral aber wir
schauen mal weiter sie spendet große
Summen an wohltätige Zwecke und macht
ihrer Community krasse Geschenke ja
das muss man ja aber auch sagen dass
sowas ja einfach Marketing ist sie gibt
da keine Ahnung 10000 € bei Apple aus
und bei irgendwelchen fashion Marken und
sagt hey ihr könnt das Gewinn ich habe
das für euch gekauft aber die Leute
müssen ja dafür folgen oder müssen einen
Newsletter abonnieren oder müssen
kommentieren wodurch ihre Reichweite das
ist einfach nur investiertes Geld was
dann zurückkommt deswegen bin ich auch
kein Fan von diesen ganzen
materialistischen Gewinnspiel wenn man
mein Content feiert sondern mir folgen
wenn nicht dann nicht aber egal Quatsch
zu viel katja hat auch einen eigenen
Softdrink
oh der will irgendwie so gar nicht zu
ihrer Mission passen ihren Fans zu
helfen
schauen wir uns das mal genauer an ja es
geht höchstwahrscheinlich um den ganzen
Zucker der da drin ist
ich habe da auch schon extrem viele
Sachen zugesehen von
Weltgesundheitsorganisation und blabla
dass dieses Getränk so ca das schlimmste
ist was man eigentlich trinken kann
einfach da sind Stoffe drin die in
anderen Ländern wieder in der Schweiz
hat sich damals mitbekommen einfach
verboten sind und da drin ist einfach 33
Gramm Zucker
Leute trinkt Wasser
Cristiano Ronaldo und ich sind so
[Musik]
jetzt muss man auch mal ganz kurz sagen
das Videos von Simpson muss das ist ein
brutal kranker YouTube Kanal ich habe
euch die Jungs Mann in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt schaut auf
jeden Fall mal vorbei wir es gibt
natürlich das Video und schauen uns das
nicht komplett dann aber die haben so
Kranke Videos also schaut bitte bei den
Jungs vorbei die Leisten eine über
Kranke Arbeit es gibt einen sugar Mami
Benzer damit turt Katja durch
Deutschland um ihre neuen Drinks
vorzustellen einige auserwählte dürfen
oder irgendwie sowas ich weiß nicht ob
ich dazu einmal bin oder zu
gesundheitsbewusst so klar ich gehe auch
mal am Wochenende feiern ich jetzt auch
mein Keks und Gottes Willen darum geht's
gar nicht aber die Dosis macht das Gift
und das ist halt das das Ding und Kids
hauen sich ja teilweise das da den
ganzen Tag rein
generell wie kann man sowas feiern und
gern trinken dass Leute die so etwas
feiern und sich sowas freiwillig
reinkippen in den Körper die bestellen
noch bei so einer schönen
italienischen familieneis die du
bestellen in unserem
blaue im August kommt das Getränk dann
endlich auf den Markt im ersten Monat
werden 10 Millionen Dosen geliefert ja
aber da muss man ja immer auch noch mal
dazu sagen dass es ja nicht die
verkaufte Menge ist
die können auch 2 Milliarden Dosen
liefern die nachher davon 1,9 Milliarden
wieder zurücknehmen müssen oder der
andere die nicht abnimmt dann ist es
halt was anderes Zucker Mami gibt es in
vier verschiedenen Sorten Granatapfel
Erdbeere Pfirsich Cherry Lollipop und
Kaktusfeige Pfirsich
das passt ganz gut das ist jetzt gerade
eigene Bild ist meiner Ansicht nach
mittlerweile der over ratest Geschmack
den es gibt
alles gibt es mittlerweile in 40
Geschmack das regt mich einfach nur noch
auf einer Getränk mit sehr sehr viel
Zucker 9 Gramm auf 100 Milliliter
mega süß also in meinem Fall ist es
nicht das ist so krass 100 Milliliter
9 Gramm
vor also ich glaube das ist in diesem
Video hier hinsichtlich Doppelmoral von
Katja krasavice darum geht dass sie das
irgendwie als gut verkauft das Getränk
aber ist einfach nur
gesundheitsschädlich ist
und
so wie es im Prinzip muss kennen werden
wahrscheinlich noch irgendwelche
Statistiken Einblendungen da kommen
deswegen halte ich jetzt einfach mal
meine Schnauze aber das ist brotal was
man sich da reingibt bevor wir jetzt
allerdings jeden Moment hier das Video
weiter gucken möchte ich auch noch mal
ganz kurz klarstellen so wie ich das
immer reactions mache dass das hier kein
persönlich sein soll es geht ja
logischerweise Getränke also nicht um
sie selber klar geht es um Aussagen
wahrscheinlich von ihr wie sie das Ding
supportet und darstellt aber hier jetzt
nichts persönlich den Kat der Kaiser
Witz ich kann ihre Musik überhaupt
nichts anfangen ich fahre jetzt
überhaupt nicht wenn ihr feiert völlig
in Ordnung Geschmäcker sind
unterschiedlich ich habe natürlich
Vorgeschichte mit Katja krasavice ich
kann mich noch daran erinnern der damals
wo sie noch keine Musikerin waren in dem
Sinne sondern wirklich Youtube Videos
gemacht hat aber skurrile Themen er hat
sie auch ein Video gemacht mit diesem
Youtuber hatte ich Wasser dann ein Bild
von mir ausgewählt auf damit
überhaupt nicht gestimmt hat ich habe
auch Songs von ihr reagiert wo sie mir
alle Einnahmen weggenommen hat obwohl
das eigentlich in der reaction Szene
gegangen und gäbe ist dass man
aufeinander reagiert und dass er
eigentlich auch passen sollte also ich
habe Vorgeschichte mit ihr aber das
sollte nicht mit reinspielen es soll
hier glaube ich heute nur um das Getränk
in von der schauen wir mal weiter pS Ich
enthält also 9 Gramm Zucker pro 100
Milliliter mehr als 100 Apfel Erdbeere
10 das ist grob so viel wie eine
reguläre Cola klar Zucker ist überall
drin und etwas Süßes hier und da muss
man auch nicht verteufeln ja das habe
ich auch vorhin gesagt die Dosis macht
das Gift es ist ja nicht schlimm am Tag
meiner halbe Stunde zu zocken oder
einmal in der Woche mal so eine ein
Liter Colaflasche zu trinken und auch so
Sachen wie Schokolade ich finde wo jeder
an sich aber ich finde Schokolade ist
sogar wirklich somit das ekelhaftes auf
der Welt ich mag das gar nicht man ist
diese schwarze Zeug es gibt zwischen den
Zähne das ist nur Zucker dann ich mag
das gar nicht keine Ahnung vielleicht
bin ich da auch ein bisschen weird aber
lasst euch das jetzt wie gesagt hier
nicht verteufeln eine ausgewogene
Ernährung ist richtig und richtig ein
Zuhörer Zuckerkonsum erhöht das Karies
Risiko kannst du Übergewicht führen und
macht anfälliger für andere Krankheiten
auf Erkrankungen
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation
empfiehlt Grund zusätzlich so wenig
Zucker wie möglich zu sich zu nehmen um
das Risiko für Karies und Übergewicht zu
reduzieren legt sie nahe maximal 25
Gramm pro Tag zu konsumieren ihr müsst
das mal checken das ist in einem seiner
sugar mamidose schon überschritten wie
gesagt es ist nicht schlimm mal eine
Cola zu trinken um Gottes Willen trinkt
euch auch man Energy Drink es war auch
total scheiße
das Schlimmste was du machen kannst aber
Wasser ist so wichtig gerade das macht
Softdrinks allgemein so problematisch
für die Gesundheit man kann richtig viel
davon trinken ohne dass der Hunger
gestillt wird genau das gleiche mit
Cornflakes
ich für meinte ich es halt nur so
Haferflocken dann als Porridge
vielleicht mal mit Hafermilch ein
bisschen Früchten und sowas alles aber
auch Cornflakes wie bereits gesagt es
ist nicht schlimm wenn jemand eine
Schale Schoko Cornflakes ist alles gut
man soll sich auch mal was gönnen um
Gottes Willen aber auch das müsst ihr
euch mal merken oder werde ich
vielleicht schon auf man kann so viele
Schalen Kontext erstmal das nur Zucker
ist du bist davon nichts hat also das
ist jetzt auch kein explizit an sugar
Mami das wird natürlich als Beispiel
genommen und plakativ darzustellen
anhand von Katja krasavice
Videos hier allerdings geht es natürlich
komplett um Softdrinks ne Cola ist
genauso unterschiedlich fand das Sprite
Monster Energy Red Bull kann man ja
alles so sagen Red Bull beispielsweise
alle Youtuber meiner Größenordnung haben
Kooperation
ich trink auch mal ab und zu ein Red
Bull aber ich finde es problematisch das
in diesem Ausmaß zu bewerben wie das
andere machen auf Instagram wurde Katja
von einem Fan gefragt ob es vielleicht
eine Variante ohne Zucker geben wird
Ihre Antwort nein wenn du zuckerfrei
willst kauf dir ein Wasser
auch meine Reaktion gerade
klar das Getränk heißt doch schon sugar
Mami also das impliziert das da Zucker
drin ist aber das kann ja dann auch noch
das als Probe benutzt und sagt hey du
bist ein Opfer dann trink halt Wasser so
mäßig
ursprünglich war sugar Mami gar nicht
als Limonade sondern als Energy Drink
geplant meine ich will das unbedingt
probieren das 9 Jahre alt und meine
Nichte auch die fünf
aah
also Energy Drink geht nicht klar für
95-Jährige aber sugar Mami mit 33 Gramm
Zucker kannst du die als Kind was nicht
mehr in die Grundschule geht schon
reinhauen
für jeden ich
finde sowas erfrischend
niemals gesagt dass meine subjektive
Meinung aber ich finde erfrischend ist
so ein Wasser mit einer Scheibe Zitrone
Limette oder vielleicht auch Minze
irgendwas damit drin und ein Eiswürfel
klar wenn du fällst von Katja krasavice
kauf dir so schon bei Mami bringt das
mal alles gut kannst du supporten und
trinkst an dieses Getränk so alles easy
aber ausgewogene Ernährung sind echt
sehr sehr sehr wichtig und viele denken
dann wenn sie so ein Vitamin water
trinkt oder so dass sie dann auch ihrem
Körper wieder was gutes tun aber
Vitamin Wasser finde ich auch echt
problematisch so dass er auch Zucker
drin plus du hauste Vitamine rein die
dein Körper wahrscheinlich gar nicht
braucht wir nehmen ja schon so viel über
die Nahrung zu uns dass das dann eh
ausgeschieden wird dann kannst du auch
direkt ein Eistee trinken auf der sugar
Mami Webseite sucht man vergeblich nach
einem wahren Hinweis aufgrund des
Fehlern Zuckers dafür findet man aber
einen anderen e122 und e129 ja das sind
so
farbveränderungsmittel irgendwie sowas
und das meinte ich auch schon eingangs
dass die also ich hoffe ich sage jetzt
nicht irgendwas Falsches aber auf jeden
Fall irgendwie in voll vielen anderen
einfach verboten sind Gesundheit sind
Zusammenhang mit Konzentrationsschwächen
bei Kindern zu geben in einigen Ländern
ist der rote Farbstoff e129 z.B bereits
verboten und das sind jetzt nicht so
Länder die jetzt irgendwie Asien sind
oder weit weg von uns sondern einfach
unser Nachbarländer Dänemark Belgien
Frankreich Schweiz
da gibt es einfach sogar Mami nicht weil
die sagen das ist zu gefährdend was dort
drin ist es ist schon schon echt irre
katja hat Videos von sehr jungen Kindern
in ihrer Story geteilt die ihre
Softdrinks trinken diesen jungen
bezeichnet sie als Playboy mit
wie alt ist der
ey die Eltern werden schon wissen was
sie tun und was sie ihren Kindern geben
und was nicht aber wohl gut der ist vier
der darf das eigentlich noch gar nicht
trinken katja ist in dem Video gerade
auf dem Weg zu einer ärmeren Familie mit
mehreren Kindern die sie zu Weihnachten
beschenken wird bei dieser Aktion waren
übrigens auch Kameras von VOX dabei für
etwas herzerwärmendes reality TV
ich finde es schön wenn man sagt man
hilft
aber wenn man das dann so eine große
Glocke hängt mit Kamerateams von VOX und
so ein Krams dann finde ich es ein
bisschen schwierig auch alle die dann so
gesagt haben hey ich habe jetzt hier
gespendet an der Türkei und blablabla
ich habe auch groß gespendet ich habe
jetzt aber nicht irgendwie Fett gesagt
ey guckt mal hier der Spenden Beleg so
klar damals wo ich gesagt habe hey Luca
Shop wir verkaufen Sachen alles was wir
den äh als erlöst haben wird gespendet
da habe ich das natürlich gepostet um
euch halt zu zeigen guck mal das kam an
aber ich finde es selbstverständlich
dass man hilft erst recht wenn man
monetär gesehen in einer besseren
Position ist als vielleicht andere Leute
wenn man das dann aber so krass hier
begleiten muss und ja weiß ich bin immer
so ein Fan von das ist so ein
zweistellige schwer das ist schön zu
helfen aber dann
naja darum soll es nicht gehen sie kennt
und lebt ihre Community und will am
liebsten jedem einen Wunsch erfüllen
aber Moment mal einen kleinen Haken gibt
es doch bevor sie etwas zurückgibt muss
man vorher noch schneller machen und ihr
bei Instagram und tiktok folgen
das ist halt so ein bisschen
Grinch halt zu sagen hey mir geht's so
schlecht gerade ich möchte euch helfen
Blabla das Gewinnspiel geht noch drei
Tage in dem Teil folgt mir
kann ich verstehen dass das so ein
bisschen hate gab wie bereits gesagt es
ist schön wenn man helfen möchte
Gewinnspiele sind auch cool Katja
krasavice sugar Mami ist nur ein
Auswuchs eines größeren Trends bei dem
bekannte Persönlichkeiten schamlos
Zucker an junge Fans vermagten oh Mann
ich dachte ich werde vielleicht auch
gezeigt also ich achte da eigentlich
schon sehr drauf klar wie gesagt die
Dosis macht das Gift um Gottes Willen es
ist nicht schlimm mein Kekse essen das
ist auch ich finde wenn man jetzt auch
so Werbung komplett verbieten sollte für
Sachen die ungesund sind
ich meine wir können uns ja auch nicht
alle jeden Tag nur von Haferflocken
Avocado und Wasser ernähren das ist
natürlich auch dann irgendwie blöd aber
ich finde es auch schwierig wenn wenn
soll Kranke zuckerhaltigen Produkte
rausgebracht werden logisch klar ich
habe auch eine Tiefkühlpizza damals raus
gemacht vor einigen Jahren sowas in die
Richtung will ich jetzt glaube ich auch
nicht noch mal machen weil ich mir auch
dachte ey Pizza ist auch nicht so das
gesündeste ich liebe Pizza ich stehe da
wie sonst was für dich
besser ist auf der ganzen Welt aber da
ist ja auch wieder der Unterschied eine
Tiefkühlpizza die kaufst du nicht und
Konsum hier direkt die pack das erstmal
zu Hause ins Eisfach ist die dann
vielleicht eine Woche später wenn du am
Sonntag irgendwie Supermärkte zu haben
oder so und das ist nicht so wie jetzt
so ein sugar Mami Drink geh rein machst
du auf kippst ihn dir rein und ist noch
deutlich ungesundheit so eine Pizza rate
vom Rapper capital bra gibt es ebenfalls
nur mit Zucker wenn du weniger als in
den Drinks von Sugar Mami Shirin david
hat 2021 dir krass gebracht zuerst gab
es auch nur drei zuckerhaltige Varianten
mittlerweile gibt es eine Zero Version
und einen Energy Drink mit Koffein der
explizit nicht für Kinder und Schwangere
geeignet ist das ist schon irre ne
ich glaube zu Shirin David und ihrer
ganzen Doppelmoral da müsste es ein
bisschen was eigentlich auch noch mal
ein Video machen ist auch wie gesagt
nichts persönliches um Gottes Willen ich
habe Geschehen zweimal getroffen sie ist
ein unfassbar lieber und Herzens guter
Mensch aber es ist natürlich schon
schwierig wenn du a sagst und B machst
ja gut ich habe glaube ich genug
gequatscht an der Stelle würde ich das
Video jetzt auch beenden es soll jetzt
wirklich nicht so rüberkommen als wenn
das hier hält dann katja krasavice ist
wie gesagt ich habe mit ihr nicht zu tun
ich habe nichts gegen die persönlich
hier ging es ja auch nur um ihr Getränk
und das ist halt wirklich
gesundheitsgefährdend es ist äh aber bei
ganz vielen Softdrinks der Fall und es
ist sollte er finde ich auf die ganze
Szene auch mal betrachtet werden weil
nicht nur Katja daran schuld ist das
jetzt Kinder übergewichtig sind oder
keine Ahnung was sondern einfach
generell diese gesunde Ernährung sollte
viel mehr in den Vordergrund gerückt und
ins Rampenlicht werden so dass alle und
insbesondere Kinder mal checken was sie
eigentlich dort trinken
es wird immer krass angepriesen erst
recht wenn Influenza und irgendwelche
Vorbilder von kleinen Kids dafür werben
aber es ist sehr sehr scheiße für den
Körper und das ist einfach Fakt ich weiß
dass viele dieses Video von mir jetzt
auch haten werden aber ich finde in
manchen Situationen ist sowas zu sagen
wirklich mal wichtig ihr kennt meine
Ansicht ich trink jeden Tag meine 45
Liter Wasser ähm dann vielleicht auch
einiges zu viel Schlimmes so ein paar
wichtige Nährstoffe mit raus ich brauche
aber wirklich so viel ich bin 1,94 ich
mache fast jeden Tag Sport und ähm kann
ich einfach nur sagen ausgewogene
Ernährung ist das A und O im Leben und
euer Körper wird euch danken auf Dauer
von daher wenn es euch gefallen hat lass
gern einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um weiter passen ich muss
Wasser in die